[Musique]
alors moi j'ai la lourde charge ce soir
de vous expliquer que la croissance on
verra si l'essentiel de mon intervention
est en fait je vais vous l'expliquer à
travers le prisme énergie et climat
tiens je vais vous parler de deux sujets
qui sont la question énergétique et la
question climatique la moitié du temps
je fais à une échelle plus modeste que
la vôtre le chef d'entreprise puisque je
co dirige carbone 4 qui compte du reste
au moins de clients dans cette sale
quart 24 aujourd'hui fait à la fois du
conseil de la fourniture de données pour
le monde financier de la formation et de
l'empreinte carbone personnel entre un
quart et un cinquième de mon temps je
préside le chi project qui est une
association d'entreprises qui milite
pour la décarbonation de l'économie et
enfin
une partie du reste du temps je fais des
interventions j'enseigne je suis membre
du haut conseil pour le climat mais tout
ça c'est j'ai envie de dire c'est la
partie médiatiquement émergée de
l'iceberg mais l'iceberg c'est carbone 4
et 6 projets
comme vous êtes des gens pressés et que
je n'aurai pas le temps de détailler
tous qu'il faudrait que vous sachiez
donc trouver un cours dans cet excellent
livre parce qu'en fait c'est un cours
donc c'est un cours qui est expliqué
renoncer en bd mais ça reste quand même
un secours il parle de choses la
première chose dont il parle c'est de
l'énergie l'énergie est une notion qui
est pas si simple que ça a expliqué au
commun des mortels et en particulier
quand on prononce le mot dans une
enceinte à peu près n'importe où en
général les réflexes pavloviens qui
viennent à l'esprit concerne tous sauf
la définition correcte d'humour vous
savez qu'il ya un ministre de la
transition énergétique
selva n'a pas santé et bien c'est pas
complètement sûr que la ministre de la
transition énergétique sache définir de
façon rigoureuse très exactement ce
qu'est l'énergie probablement capable
d'en parler parce que
dans les réflexes qui viennent à
l'esprit quand on parle d'énergie il y
en a un qui est particulièrement
prégnant en ce moment qui est que ça
coûte cher certes ça coûte cher quand on
l'achète ça coûte cher quand c'est des
sites et ça coûte cher quand c'est du
gaz ça coûte cher 27 d'essence en fait
vous allez voir un peu plus tard que ça
coûte pas cher du tout et en plus
rentrer dans l'énergie par le prisme de
son coup c'est raté complètement
l'importance que l'énergie occupe
aujourd'hui dans la structuration du
monde une deuxième manière de rentrer
dans l'énergie et de parler d'économie
alors c'est particulièrement là aussi à
la mode en ce moment avec ce qui se
passe en ukraine et les interrogations
que nous commençons à avoir sur
l'approvisionnement en pétrole et en gaz
alors c'est une interrogation que nous
avons de temps en temps c'est un
discours qu'on entend de temps en temps
maintenant quand on regarde ce qui s'est
passé sur le siècle et demi écoulés même
avant l'énergie l'a jamais économisé à
l'échelle planétaire vous avez ici une
reconstitution de la quantité totale
d'énergie qui est utilisé par l'humanité
depuis un siècle et demi est ce que vous
voyez sur ce graphique c'est plusieurs
choses la première c'est que sur ce
siècle et demi jamais la quantité peut
peut-être d'énergie utilisé sur terre
n'a baissé la deuxième chose que vous
voyez c'est que les diverses formes
d'énergie que nous utilisons aujourd'hui
se sont empilées les unes sur les autres
il n'y a jamais eu à large échelle
d'exclusion d'une forme d'énergie par
une autre donc vous voyez que le charbon
là il s'est empilé par dessus les
renouvelables le enfin parce que la
biomasse biomasse qui constituent l
essentiel de l'approvisionnement il ya
un siècle et demi donc il ya un siècle
et demi le monde était quasiment 100%
renouvelable et reviendrait dans pas
longtemps donc un monde sans qu'on s'en
rende ou la brosse pas de problème on
s'est enfin fait donc un problème c'est
celui quand on vient
par dessus on a empilé de charbon il par
dessus on empilait le pétrole qui n'a
pas remplacer le charbon parution dans
des cases et c est ce que vous voyez
tout en haut là en rose c'est les
nouvelles énergies renouvelables donc
celle agrégats du solaire de l'éolien du
mari moteur du lot moteur du biogaz de
la géothermie et je dois en oublier ou
200 vous voyez ce que ça représente à
l'échelle planétaire et vous voyez
surtout que leur augmentation sur les 20
dernières années n'a absolument pas
empêché toujours sur les 20 dernières
années le charbon d'augmenter très
fortement le pétrole d'augmenter
fortement le gaz d'augmenter très
fortement ce qui fait que quand vous
regardez la part des énergies fossiles
dans l'approvisionnement énergétique
mondial elle est aujourd'hui de 80 %
exactement comme elle était de 80% en
l'essentiel de ce que nous utilisons
aujourd'hui c'est des énergies fossiles
et le développement de l'ère
industrielle
c'est précisément sortir des énergies
renouvelables pour entrer dans les
énergies fossiles c'est précisément ça
développement de l'industrie
troisième réflexe qui d'où vient donc
maintenant à l'esprit donc il faut
retourner au 100% renouvelable mais
évidemment en conservant la société
industrielle alors je le redis aller
vers un monde sans qu'on s'en rende ou
l'art de pose aucun problème voilà par
exemple un monde sans qu'on s'en rende
ou là mais j'aurais pu vous montrer
n'importe quel tableau de n'importe
quelle société humaine jusqu'à ya deux
siècles que vous aurez montré un tableau
d'une société 100% renouvelable encore
donc je le redis faire un monde sans
qu'on s'en rende oulab ne pose aucun
problème à monde 100 % renouvelable avec
le fond agro croissance de patients
donc c'est bien ça la question est ce
qu'on saura faire à mon sens qu'on sent
renouvelables avec le pouvoir d'achat
qu'on a aujourd'hui la civilisation
industrielle qu'on a aujourd'hui la
mondialisation et des places de cinéma
pas cher et bien c'est la question qu'il
faut se poser et vous allez voir à la
fin de cet exposé qu'il n'est pas
complètement sûr que la réponse soit oui
ta bonne réponse en ce qui concerne
l'énergie alors je vais vous donner la
réponse scientifique et puis ensuite je
vais vous donner la réponse dans la vie
de tous les jours la réponse
scientifique c'est que l'énergie c'est
par définition en physique ce qui
quantifie le changement d'état d'un
système c'est ça la définition de
l'énergie donc l'énergie est une
grandeur physique
elle caractérise les changements d'état
d'un système n'importe quel système qui
change de température de vitesse de
formes de couleurs de composition
chimique de composition atomique etc
dans n'importe laquelle de ces
transformations vous avez de l'énergie
qui entrent en jeu et la quantité
d'énergie qui entrent en jeu le
quantifie le degré de transformation du
système
1plusv ou surgelés un aliment bas plus
vous avez transformé par rapport à son
état initial que vous avez utilisé
d'énergies plus vous déplacer une boîte
de conserve loin plus vous avez
transformé par rapport à l'état initial
plus vous avez utilisé des donc
l'énergie c'est l'unité de compte de la
transformation alors dans la vie de tous
les jours moi je lui donne un autre nom
addénergie c'est comme vous le voyez de
réponse dès donc voici des
décès comme vous le reconnaissez sur
cette planche c'est le costume d'iron
man alors pourquoi est ce que je dis que
l'énergie c'est iron man en fait je ne
dis pas que l'énergie cet ironman jeudi
que l'énergie c'est la nourriture et
l'énergie ses croquettes d'iron man iron
man c'est le costume aujourd'hui nous
portons toutes et tous sur nos épaules
en permanence
si vous portez en permanence le costume
d'iron man sur vos épaules comme moi
alors il n'a pas la tête du costume
d'iron man il a c'est peut-être là mais
il remplit exactement les mêmes
fonctions
notre costume d'iron man aujourd'hui
c'est le parc de machines que nous avons
sur terre dont je vais vous montrer
maintenant que la puissance est
absolument faramineuses par rapport à la
puissance de nos propres carcasse et que
ce temps ce parc de machines daube et
aux combustibles fossiles on pourrait
oublier les retours sur investissements
à 10% par an dans l'agroalimentaire
or ça n'existera qu'en disent ses
problèmes en les mauvaises années dans
les bois
je vais vous donner maintenant quelques
exemples de petits bouts de ce costume
d'iron man dont vacants à commencer par
le gros orteil d'iron man qui s'appelle
un tracteur et bien attracteur si vous
faites un rapide calcul le moteur d'un
tracteur c'est un petit tracteur un
céréalier dans la bouche
quelques dizaines de kilos va tu es bien
développe en pratique la même puissance
que quelques centaines de paires de
jambes sur une journée moyenne d'un
cycliste bien entraîné donc quand je
mets un tracteur dans les chambres il
est capable de faire le travail de
quelques centaines de paysans ou de
quelques dizaines d'animaux de trait à
la différence près que les animaux de
trait ont besoin d'autres champs pour se
nourrir mon tracteur il a besoin du sous
sol pour se nourrir donc grâce aux
tracteurs on libère la totalité de la
surface pour les ans n'a plus besoin de
la surface pour les animaux tu
prenais une moissonneuse batteuse là
j'ai pris la plus grosse que j'ai trouvé
je possède je ne dirais pas qui la
fabrique là on devient un peu plus
sérieux 500 kilowatts donc elle a la
même puissance de traction que 5000 fois
compagnie fait pantani pas réussi un peu
moins bien un bon cycliste du dimanche
voilà bien entraîné il en faut 5 milles
attelé 2 pour tracter avec la même
puissance sauf que ça coûte pas de
mépris
la moissonneuse batteuse l'a
considérablement moins chers que si vous
deviez embauché cinq mille personnes au
smic pour tirer l'engin
voilà maintenant d'autres auxiliaires
très utile de l'agriculture enfin très
utile très puissant plus exactement vous
aurez reconnu évidemment voulait tous
les jours des usines d'engrais et
phytosanitaires
c'est un des maillons de l'usiné de la
pétrochimie et n'a pas la première usine
venu en matière de chimie elle vous fait
quelques centaines de mégawatts et donc
pour la faire tourner s'il fallait que
ce soit des êtres humains qui la fasse
tourner il faudrait avoir des centaines
de milliers des millions de travailleurs
pour mouliner comme sur les bateaux de
course vous savez les gens qui voyagent
ou pour pédaler comme sharp et winston
dans soleil vert
donc pour remplacer une seule de ses
usines si on n'avait pas les machines il
faudrait des centaines de milliers ou
des millions de personnes continuent
vous avez besoin dans l'agriculture
également de faire venir des engrais
phosphatés ou potassique sa transitent
par minéraliers et bien un minéralier in
pédales le botteur du minéralier il
[ __ ] comme 208 x les jambes des
capitaines donc là c'est pareil si je
devais avoir 200 en l'occurrence plutôt
2 millions de galériens
on devrait prendre 10% de la population
active française
si pour elle envoyé aux galères rien que
pour développer la même puissance que le
moteur d'un seul de ces minéralier
un camion qui sont absolument partout
aujourd'hui est bien le moteur d'un
camion développe la même puissance que
des milliers de fois les jambes du
conducteur et à laminoir aussi un
laminoir c'est un auxiliaire
indispensable de la civilisation
industrielle vos usines n'existerait pas
sans amis noirs les engins agricoles
n'existerait pas sans laminoir les
camions n'existerait pas sans le mi-noir
donc sans l'acier notre civilisation
n'existent pas eh bien pour remplacer un
laminoir on en a au moins deux en france
la connaissance dunkerque et fos sur mer
pour remplacer un laminoir il faut que
j'emploie la moitié sans machine dont
500 machines il faudrait que je mette au
travail avec des marteaux dans les mains
à taper sur la toile toute la journée la
moitié de la population active du privé
en france
d'accord je prends la moitié de la salle
la l'envoi taper sur des taux la fosse
votre moitié de la salle on va taper sur
l'épaule d'un gars
je fais ça partout dans le vide avant en
fait rien d'autre qui aurait pas la
civilisation mais c'est juste pour vous
dire à quel point les machines sont
aujourd'hui omniprésentes et à quel
point elles sont extrêmement puissante
alors si je prends une petit déjeuner et
bien votre petit déjeuner c'est des
machines et de l'énergie ce que vous
avez dans votre assiette a été cultivée
par des engins par des gens si on rédige
les engins du reste on n'a plus besoin
des gens
vous avez utilisé des phytosanitaires
qui viennent de l'industrie pétrolière
vous avez utilisé les flux en plastique
vous avez utilisé de l'industrie
chimique ah bon
vous avez utilisé des beats de potasse
et de phosphates sans une
également vous avez utilisé des trains
vous avez utilisé des camions vous avez
utilisé des machines dans les usines
vous avez utilisé de la fabrication
d'emballages vous avez utilisé des
camions vous avez utilisé des engins
pour réfrigérer ou pour chauffer voilà
toutes les machines que vous avez
utilisé juste pour avaler un bol de
céréales un café au lait ou une partie
j'aurais également pu vous faire la
liste de toutes les machines qu'on
travaillait pour vous enfilez un slip ou
une cravate bref nous vivons aujourd'hui
dans un monde de machines vous vous en
rendez pas compte mais le moindre de nos
gestes du quotidien a mobilisé des
milliers des millions des milliards de
machines pour que nous puissions vivre
comme nous vivons aujourd'hui
et ces machines participent également
d'une économie totalement mondialisé
vous êtes tous et tout comme moi du
reste inscrit dans une économie
mondialisée dès lors que vous utilisez
un emballage en métal ou en plastique
vous utilisez quelque chose qui n'a pas
trouvé son origine ans
l'appui dit de faire en france il ya pas
dans le bassin parisien
donc nous sommes tous et toutes dans une
économie mondialisée grâce aux magies
c'est ça le monde dans lequel on vit si
on fait un petit calcul d'ordre de
grandeur
le parc total de machines installées sur
terre où je vous parle grâce à ses
grands thèmes pour machines particulière
c'est à dire d'énergie il est capable de
démultiplier à tout instant la puissance
musculaire de l'humanité par un facteur
2 ans
alors je peux vous le dire de trois
manières différentes cette affaire un
terrien ordinaire je parviens à therrien
ordinaire je compte pas des gens dans
cette salle pour qu'ils vivent de la
même manière qu'il vit aujourd'hui dans
un monde sans machine il faudrait qu'il
ait 200 esclaves à sa disposition
adjoint de gap
en france c'est plutôt six ans et dans
cette salle comme nous sommes des cadres
supérieurs c'est plutôt 1000 à 2000
dans un monde sans machine pour avoir le
mode de vie que vous avez aujourd'hui
vous devriez avoir deux mille esclaves à
votre disposition à jeanne gap
je vais vous le dire d'une autre manière
dans un monde sans énergie fossile donc
sans machine le pib mondial la
population constante se réaliser par
deux sens où sont mes 10 à 20% de romans
par 200 que voulait dire encore d'une
troisième manière pour avoir le même pib
qu'aujourd'hui dans un monde sans
machine il faudrait passer de 8 à 1600
milliards d'individus sur terre alors
déjà qui à 82 places
est ce que je viens de vous dire ce
rapport de 1 à 200 vous explique
pourquoi rang quand vous regardez le pib
mondial en fonction de la quantité
totale d'énergie utilisé sur terre en
fait vous êtes en train de regarder le
pib exprimé en fonction de la taille du
parc de machines en service et donc vous
êtes juste en train de regarder à
comment je mesure avec une unité d euros
des flux de transformation que le
physicien ou ingénieur peut mesurer en
jour le sait les mêmes c'est les même et
on les mesure avec deux unités
différentes des jours ou des euros alors
cette courbe est très très légèrement
convexe comme vous pouvez le voir ce qui
veut dire qu'on a un peu d'efficacité
énergétique tous les ans mais vous voyez
qu'on premier rang dis moi combien
l'humanité utilise l'énergie c'est à
dire quelle est la taille du parc de
machines qu'elle met en service et je te
dirai quelle est la taille de son pays
alors là vous comprenez que monsieur le
maire fait reprendre le pib dans un
monde en contraction énergétique parce
que c'est ça l'objectif
c'est pas gagné d'avancé
c'est pas gagné d'avancé tout ce que
nous avons vécu au 19è et au xxème
siècle je vais rapidement derrière est
la conséquence de sa l'augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat la tertiarisation la
baisse du vent d'agriculteurs les gens
qui vont se mettre dans les villes le
temps libre tout ça c'est la conséquence
de l'ère des machines tout
j'ai pas le temps on l'a suggéré une
menez c'est surtout le fait cgt et le
medef dans un monde sans énergie
j'aurais
tout ça c'est la conséquence encore une
fois de cette abondance cette
surabondance énergétique qui
malheureusement
comme l'essentiel de cette énergie
fossile vous avez aussi ici le drame des
négociateurs climat c'est à dire au
premier rang dans le pib mondial est
aussi une fonction linéaire des
émissions de co2 planétaire en fait la
même variable c'est-à-dire la quantité
d'énergie c'est-à-dire le parc de
machines en service vous donne deux
sorties du pib d'un côté du co2 de
l'autre du coup celle à peu près
proportionnelle
comme la décarbonation de l'énergie
n'arrive pas 80% de fos il ya 50 ans
aujourd'hui encore une fois au premier
rang voilà ce qui veut dire que la
neutralité carbone en 2050 sans
organiser une récession mondiale tous
les ans nue c'est juste impossible
donc nous l'aurons degrés en organisant
cette prestation ou de force avec des
accidents qu'ils approuveront sans vous
demander notre avis le colis de la
guerre en ukraine et dans variantes
possibles de la chose est sûre une
planète finie si c'est pas la tête
ça fait 50 ans que les modélisations de
l'équipe meadows web haïti voilà ont
expliqué de façon très lumineuse je vous
invite à lire ou relire ce livre
absolument géniale
de la dynamique des systèmes c'est pas
du tout de l'écologie radicale c'est
vraiment des systèmes d'acquisition et
ça vous explique pourquoi
malheureusement la croissance
perpétuelle dans un monde fini
alors voilà une courbe qui est
directement aux blogueuses de points
plus exactement qui vous explique en
quoi l'abondance des machines à déformer
la structure de l'emploi et pourquoi
aujourd'hui on veut produire beaucoup
plus de nourriture est beaucoup moins de
gens dans les chambres tout simplement
que les gens ont été remplacés par des
machines vous avez ici pour un certain
nombre de pays dans le monde chaque
point représente un pays vous avez la
part de l'emploi dans la peau la part de
l'agriculture dans l'emploi sur l'eshop
verticale et la quantité d'énergie
utilisée par personne et par an sur
l'axé horizontal et bien vous voyez que
si vous regardez aujourd'hui dans le
monde
plus un pays utilisent d'énergie par
personne - il à l'agriculteur
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé
aussi en france avec l'augmentation de
la quantité de machines en service
l'emploi agricole en france et des 60%
même ces deux tiers en 1800 c'est un
modeste de bon sens aujourd'hui alors
que la production de nourriture a été
multiplié par quatre à cinq
qu'est ce qui a fait ça les tracteurs
les engrais et les phytosanitaires
c'est à dire des machines et l'énergie
quand on n'a plus besoin des gens dans
les campagnes ils sont allés faire autre
chose alors autre chose c'est quoi avec
l'énergie abondante on a utilisé
d'autres machines que c'est la cultiver
qu'on a utilisé des machines à extraire
de terre tout rompre au 1 et à
transformer ses ressources et donc on a
fait le pistolet à eau le lecteur de dvd
les fauteuils sur lesquels vous êtes
installés et la moquette sur laquelle on
marche voilà on a fait tout cela en
extrayant des ressources de
l'environnement et en les transformant
où est ce que ça se passe le genre de
truc dans des mines et des usines où
sont les mines un peu partout où sur les
usines on les a construits là où c'était
facile d'avoir des gens en grande
quantité donc ça a créé pour partie des
vides puis une fois qu'on a remplacé les
gens dans les usines par des machines ça
s'appelle l'harmonisation à ce moment à
quoi est-ce qu'on utilise les gens à
gérer la complexité du monde qu'est ce
que vous faites de votre vos journées
qu'est ce que je fais de mes journées
nous gérons la complexité du monde
produire des comptes consolidés mettre
en place un erp et mettre en place un
crm
optimisée des lignes de production c'est
gérer la complexité du moins s'occuper
de la logistique et faire des campagnes
de publicité c'est gérer la complexité
du monde donc qu'est-ce que vous faites
de vos journées comme moi vous n'êtes
pas avec une pelle et une pioche mois
pas plus
tous autant que vous êtes comme moi on
voudrait les deux bras et deux jambes et
on vous donnerait la possibilité de
commander un ordinateur avec votre
cervelle médicaux
à peu de choses près d'agen
donc aujourd'hui nous avons merci arisée
l'économie parce que nous avons beaucoup
d'énergie c'est un truc qu'on explique
donc un pas à pas une économie tertiaire
en fait partie des cours aujourd'hui
dans une économie et un enregistrement
de conférences que j'ai fait à
l'entraînement il ya un an et demi c'est
long confiance que j'ai fait allez voir
je détaille ce que je viens de vous dire
avec plein de gourdes très très parlante
sur le lien entre énergie et
tertiarisation et on voit la
tertiarisation qui augmente à mesure que
la quantité d'énergie par personne
augmente on voit que l'emploi dans
l'agriculture diminue à mesure que la
quantité d'énergie par personne tous les
pays ont suivi exactement la même
évolution que les gouvernements et des
dictées à droite à gauche qu'ils étaient
démocratiques ou autoritaires c'est
toujours la même évolution donc on a
vidé les vies on a vidé les campagnes
effet les villes c'est la même évolution
spatiale qui s'est produite dans tous
les pays européens
dans tous les pays du monde dès que
l'énergie arrivent en masse
l'urbanisation ce qui veut dire qu'une
civilisation fortement urbanisée
contrairement à l'idée qu'on se fait
souvent n'est pas une civilisation
résiliente face à la sobriété
énergétique cette utilisation fragile
cette zone cette abondance énergétique
nous a également permis de nourrir pour
pas cher
l'inflation savons rien à mourinho la
nourriture aujourd'hui c'est
essentiellement vos marges 7 des
transporteurs et celles des
distributeurs mais c'est pas le fait de
la produire je vais vous le montrer ici
vous avez l'évolution là sur un siècle
quasiment un siècle du ticket de caisse
des ménages américains dix ans après ils
nous parlent pas des françaises tout
simplement parce que les sites
statistique français sont ainsi fait pas
de polytechniciens que vous m'aidiez un
quart d'heure on va trouver ce que vous
voulez alors aux états unis
j'ai jamais trop classe quelqu'un sait
comment faire je suis preneur mais c'est
la même chose la démonstration
donc vous avez ici l'audit de la
dépendance alimentaire des ménages
américains ce que vous voyez c'est qu'il
ya un siècle en 1930 les ménages
américains m un quart de ce qu'ils
dépensent dans un long et dur et vous
voyez que au début du 21e siècle les
mêmes ménages américains mettent moins
de 10% et diront oui la nourriture a été
divisé par deux et demi fait amusant
parce que il ya un siècle alors je suis
désolé pour ses propos sexiste mais la
bouche et les oreilles mais c'est la
réalité de ce qui se passait à l'époque
qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya un siècle
eh bien madame michu louhalamou smic
plus exactement à acheter marché ou chez
le paysan du coin ou veulent récupérer
pour partie du réseautage et des patates
et les yeux pour faire le frichti pour
monsieur cliff qui est partie aux champs
ou qui est parti à l'usiné ce qui veut
dire que l'essentiel de la dépense
alimentaire des ménages à cette époque
là c'était produit brut ce que les gens
vont cuisiner eux-mêmes
qu'est ce que ces critiques la dépenses
alimentaires aujourd'hui en france à 90%
c'est ma grande distribution et là
dedans pour une bonne partie des
produits que vous fabriquez
c'est des produits issus de
l'agroalimentaire or les produits vous
fabriquer les matières premières
agricoles dedans c'est une part
minoritaire du ticket de caisse quant à
personnes passent à la caisse
aujourd'hui chez carrouf dans un autre
distributeur ou va payer le salaire du
magasinier le salaire de la caissière le
salaire du transporteur le salaire de la
duty qui a construit ce magasin le
salaire les dividendes des actionnaires
la campagne de pub de carouge les gens
qui ont fait les emballages pour que les
produits les marges des industriels de
l'agroalimentaire etc tout ça on va
payer tout ça c'est pas de la nourriture
ce qu'on va vraiment payé en nourriture
c'est une part très minoritaire et je
vais prendre un exemple qui allez zou
une boîte d'oeufs de poule en batterie
au supermarché ça coûte aujourd'hui de
l'ordre de 20 euros 50
un beau but love alors ça c'était avant
que vis de l'inflation du prix des
céréales mais on va dire il ya six mois
love sorti d'élevage industriel c'était
706 voix 6 36 ça veut dire que la boîte
de 36 centimes en une production la
payer 1 euro 50 au magasin c'est que des
marchands
c'est pas la bouffe c'est que des marges
en transport distribution plus
ce qui veut dire que aujourd'hui le
ticket de caisse de monsieur madame si
quand ils sortent chez walmart au mieux
ses 20% de nourriture qu'il ya dedans et
si monsieur et madame smith son
restaurant si vous allez vous mangez une
noble est donc à fait de bercy qui est
en face vous allez payer six euros vous
allez également en prendre trois autres
poules en batterie à l'e3 offert des
titres avec vous donc vous allez avoir
de 20 à 30 centimes 2 dans un truc que
vous allez payer simplement
or donc vous payez pas la nourriture
pays tout le reste nous voyez du
restaurant le salaire de la serveuse au
niveau du serveur
donc si vous allez au restaurant quand
vous regardez donc si vous ramenez
vraiment au prix de la nourriture en
fait ce dont vous vous rendez compte
c'est que le prix des aliments il a été
divisé par 10 à 20 le prix du la part de
la nourriture a été divisé par 10 à 20
ça correspond à l'effondrement de
l'emploi agricole dans le pib
et dans le même temps la quantité de
viande qu'on mange a été multiplié par
3,5 donc le prix de la viande lui il a
carrément été divisée par cinq ans
c'est ça l'abondance énergétique s'est
divisé le prix des aliments donc dans un
monde sans énergie vous faites tous
faillite moi aussi du reste parce qu'un
consultant comme je disais tout à
l'heure se nourrit de la complexité du
monde qui a pas besoin de consultant
dans
mon métier on en arrive
[Musique]
donc l'histoire des 19e et 20e siècles
est la suivante nous avons sous terre
des combustibles fossiles
qui sont gratuits bien que non non mais
qu'on visite fossiles sont réduits
toutes les ressources naturelles sont
gratuites dans la convention économique
vous n'avez pas dans les comptes de vos
entreprises quoique ce soit qui concerne
le fait et 20% d'oxygène dans l'air
pourtant si je vous met dans une
atmosphère totalement saturée d'azoté
100% amazon tous les gens qui
travaillent chez demeure et donc le
chiffre d'affaires pour 0 d'accord il
n'y a rien dans les comptes de vos
entreprises qui disent que vous dépendez
de l'oxygène dans l'air
il ya 40 ans dépendants eh bien il n'y a
rien non plus dans les comptes de vos
entreprises qui dit qui prévoit quoi que
ce soit pour le pétrole ce qui coûte
pour le pétrole c'est des gens qu'on va
payer pour faire sortir de terre leurs
affidés l'existence même du pétrole
sauter c'est gratuit exactement comme le
vent et le soleil exactement comme
l'existence de l'océan l'existence du
mont blanc l'existence de la mer
méditerranée et l'existence du sable sur
les plages tout ça c'est gratuit tout ça
c'est gratuit ces ressources naturelles
qui nous ont été donnés gratuitement par
la nature dans la convention et connaît
donc le pétrole est gratuit il est aussi
gratuite le vent et soleil tant qu'il ya
personne pour aller le chercher
les combustibles fossiles brûle ça nous
permet d'alimenter des machines qui nous
ont permis de transformer la totalité de
ce qui nous tombait sous la main et
comme je viens de l'expliquer ça nous a
fait la structure actuelle les métiers
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat ça
nous a fait le système de soins ça nous
a fait les congés ça nous a presque
comme les machines possèdent en place on
peut travailler 35 heures par semaine
peut avoir six semaines de congés payés
à vous travaillez en plus si on peut
avoir les congés payés on peut avoir les
études longues on peut avoir la retraite
n'avait pas de retraite dans le monde
avant l'énergie abondante
n'existait absolument pas il n'y avait
pas les études donc pour tous non plus
il n'y avait pas non plus donc tout ça
ça nous a été amené par l'abondance
énergétique ce qui veut dire que de
s'occuper de transition énergétique
c'est bien plus profond que de
simplement se demander où est ce qu'on
va planter des éoliennes
c'est beaucoup plus profond que ça ça
veut dire qu'il va falloir réformer les
retraites on entend de parler c'est pas
la dernière fois
parfois jusqu'à ce que vous mourriez vos
enfants aussi on va s'occuper de
réformer les retraites en fait on valoir
à former en permanence parce que les
retraites dans un monde en contraction
énergétique donc en contraction
économique bah ça serait énorme en
permanence
le curseur entre les gens qui ne
travaillent plus les gens qui
travaillent pas se déplacer en
permanence c'est juste normal comme il
s'est déplacé en permanence dans l'autre
sens au moment où l'énergie arrivé de
façon de plus en plus abondante on a
organisé le territoire humides et les
campagnes etc l'énergie alors dans cette
affaire on a coutume de ne compter la
transformation du monde que sous forme
économique
malheureusement c'est une illusion
d'optique pour comprendre vraiment ce
qui se passe il faut revenir à la
physique l'économie d'aujourd'hui n'est
pas prédictive de la physique de demain
dans les prix que vous avez payé le gaz
l'année dernière il n'y avait rien qui
vous disais 'si vous en auriez ou pas
l'année d'après
rien
donc si vous voulez savoir à quoi
ressemble les flux physiques de demain
sont retournés à la physique l'économie
vous le dira jamais
jamais jamais
ce que l'économie vous dit c'est ce qui
s'est passé jusqu'à maintenant
point
dans un monde qui continue à être soumis
aux mêmes lois ok induire dans un monde
où les lois d'évolution change
rapidement
de lévis d'au moins 100 susceptible de
venir perturber ce que je viens de vous
expliquer la question du changement
climatique et la question de
l'approvisionnement énergétique je
rappelle qu'il faut 4 400 millions
d'années pour faire des combustibles
fossiles donc le charbon c'est des one
shot c'est les fougères de l'ère du
jarreau carbonifère les 300 millions
d'années donc ça on n'en fera pas une
deuxième fois le pétrole et le gaz
plancton et micro algues qui ont vécu
n'importe quand entre ya quatre il ya
400 millions d'années et qui ensuite ont
sédimenté sont fait cueillir par l'âge
et au dernier
l'ong baisse également et donc c'est non
renouvelable donc ces aidants et les
combustibles fossiles qu'on ne peut pas
reconstitué au fur et à mesure
ce qui veut dire que comme pour toute
ressource non renouvelable vous avez un
stock de débarquer donner une fois pour
toutes vous avez nécessairement un
maximum à l'extraction annuel c'est une
démonstration mathématique
et c'est nécessairement passer ce
maximum des ressources dont la
disponibilité au fil des ans diminue de
façon inexorable
va ouvrir
on va commencer par qu'il a
dans la foulée de l'utilisation des
combustibles fossiles mais pas que les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ont
considérablement augmenté sur le dernier
siècle et demi vous les voyez ici qu'est
ce que c'est qu'un gaz à effet de serre
ça une définition là aussi physique très
simple désolé de vous faire mal à la
tête avec un peu de physique c'est à gaz
qui adhéraient d'absorption dans
l'infrarouge terrestre ça veut dire que
c'est pas gaz qui quand ils voient
passer du rayonnement infrarouge de
grandes longueurs d'onde émis par la
surface de la terre qui me viens par ici
toi il n'a besoin ce faisant il chauffe
et ce faisant ils pas communiqué son
énergie à l'atmosphère environnante il
va également se débarrasser de cette
énergie en rayonnant lui aussi ce gaz
est une partie du rayonnement qu'il a
créée mais repart vers la terre et
chauffe un peu plus la terre donc là gaz
à effet de serre c'est un gaz qui va
absorber l'infrarouge terrestre
voir son énergie intrinsèque embarqué
augmenter et s'en débarrasser pour
partie en chauffe en l'air autour de lui
est parti en voyage
vers la surface un rayonnement
supplémentaire qui va s'ouvrir le plus
national
donc plus on en est dans l'air plus vous
avez la surface qui reçoit de l'énergie
en provenance de l'atmosphère
et donc l'énergie emmagasinée dans le
système avec tout un pas de conséquence
qu'on envoie ici vous avez donc les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre depuis
un siècle et demi alors vous voyez que
ces émissions elles ne font que croître
et embellir la de danger discriminer le
co2 qui vient du charbon le co2 qui
vient du pétrole le co2 qui vient du gaz
au dessus vous avez la déforestation au
dessus vous allez le méthane le méthane
est un gaz qui vous concernent
particulièrement dans cette salle parce
que tous les ruminants émettent du
méthane de manière significative la
culture du riz aimé du méthane de
manière significative les déjections
animales émettent du méthane de manière
significative
donc dès lors que vous avez des produits
animaux ou du riz dans les matières
premières que vous manipulez il ya eu
des émissions de méthane qui sont
évidemment incluse dans l'empreinte
carbone de votre activité
vous voyez que ces émissions n'ont pas
arrêté d'augmenter nonobstant tous les
développements techniques que nous avons
fait sur le siècle et demi qui vient de
s'écouler par exemple on a mis au point
les moteurs électriques et les centrales
électriques il ya de plus en plus de
centrales électriques et plus en plus de
moteur électrique ou et que ça n'a pas
empêché les émissions d'augmenter
jusqu'à maintenant on s'est mis à avoir
des gens dans les villes alors on
n'arrête pas de dire débile c'est plus
efficace énergétiquement peut-être ça
n'a pas empêché les émissions augmentent
et on s'est mis à avoir des trains c'est
les appelants échéance et végétalisé ça
n'a pas empêché et d'une manière
générale on n'a pas arrêté de faire des
trucs et des machins sur le siècle et
demi qui vient de s'écouler
aucune innovation technique n'a été de
manière autoporteuse une solution au
problème
ce qui veut dire que de se dire à
l'avenir il ya qu'à laisser les jeunes
baigneurs faire des innovations
techniques et art mode de régulation
inchangé ça va régler le problème c'est
ce pur et le doigt dans l'oeil jusqu'au
plexus
ça ne marchera pas pas plus que ça n'a
marché dans le passé pas plus que ça
doit marcher dans le passé
pour a expliqué pourquoi au monde est
question est là aucune chance que ça
marche le principal gaz à effet de serre
que nous émettons aujourd'hui est un
d'occident co2 ailleurs dioxyde de
carbone il se trouve que les oxydes ont
une propriété chimiques bien connu
ce sont des molécules extrêmement stable
les oxydes sont des molécules non
altérables sauf si vous leur envoyez
beaucoup d'énergie dessus pour
débarrasser lockheed de son oxygène
c'est une opération qu'on appelle la
réduction en chimie et qui demandent
d'utiliser des grandes quantités
d'énergie pour l'opérer c'est ça qu'on
fait par exemple avec le minerai de fer
vers mes ados 600 vous l'envoyez pas
d'énergie dessus il est stable
le co2 obéit à cette règle donc le co2
et chimiquement inerte une fois qu'il
est dans l'atmosphère dia qui
légitimement inerte ça veut dire qu'il
n'a pas de processus propane et
l'épuration
donc tant que le co2 est dans l'air il y
est éternelle pour que le co2 est bien
sortir de l'ère il faut qu'ils
reviennent au contact du sol où là il
peut être épurées soit par dissolution
dans l'océan mais c'est un processus de
masse communicants donc ça marche pas ad
vitam aeternam quand l'océan sera aussi
plein que l'atmosphère est bien ça
s'arrêtera soit être repris par la
photosynthèse et pour ça il faut que les
écosystèmes et les plantes se vendent
bien sinon la photosynthèse peut
diminuer et à ce moment de la reprise
est de luzon faible avec un effet
normalement le jour il ya plus de
photosynthèse du tout ce qui arrive au
6e ne nous intéresse pas
tous
sa capture une personne qui ait pas de
vie sur mars
donc le co2 étant extrêmement stable une
fois qu'il est dans l'atmosphère vous
avez là une des caractéristique centrale
cette affaire de région de man
climatique
à cause de nos émissions en co2 nous
avons augmenté la quantité qu'il y en a
dans la concentration
le show où nous nous arrêtons des
maîtres totalement cette concentration
atmosphérique supplémentaire que nous
avons créé avec nos émissions ne va pas
s'emballer tout de suite ce que vous dit
ce graphique en fait c'est que ceux ci
ont plus que nous avons mis dans l'air
un siècle après arrêt des émissions il
en reste encore une petite moitié
un millier d'années après l'arrêt des
émissions il en reste encore 1 25%
des mines ans après l'arrêt des
émissions il en reste encore 10 à 15%
l'atmosphère ne pourra jamais être
remise dans l'état dans lequel nous
l'avons trouvé en enfants jamais jamais
et comme
climat ne reviendra jamais dans l'état
dans lequel il était en 1850 en 18 ans
ça veut dire que certaines conséquences
de la dérive climatique à partir de
maintenant ne peuvent rien faire d'autre
que d'augmenter jusqu'à la nuit des
temps
alors la nuit des temps c'est quelques
milliers d'années voire quelques
dizaines de milliers d'années c'est à
dire beaucoup plus long beaucoup plus
longtemps pardon probablement qu'il
reste à une humanité nombreuses à vivre
mais c'est voilà vous avez les chaînes
dedans caractéristiques du problème et
vous voyez que c'est très très de la
saison et longtemps que nous avons
l'habitude de gérer que ce soit nos
propres existences que ce soit alors ça
je pense que les élections en charge et
que ce soit le à mandats présidentiels
et que ce soit évidemment la stratégie
de long terme dans une société cotée
c'est à dire
les bonnes ou l'horizon de sortie d'un
fonds de private equity sales c'est à
dire là aussi dix ans entre passion et
50 ans et moins on est sur des horizons
tant qu'ils n'ont rien à voir absolument
rien à voir avec l'horizon temps auquel
il faudrait réfléchir pour gérer
correctement ce problème vous avez ici
une carte des écosystèmes qui sont
installés en europe si on est le
supprime pas pour faire autre chose
alors je dis actuelle c'est déjà un peu
faux c'était actuelle il ya 50 ans
en europe si vous ne supprimez pas les
écosystèmes existants pour y mettre
autre chose notamment ce qui vous permet
de gérer votre activité c'est à dire des
champs et bien pouces essentiellement
des arbres essentiellement des forêts ça
veut dire que le climat est ni trop
froid ni trop chaud ni trop sec ni trop
humide il est juste comme il faut comme
pour qu'elle pousse des gros espèces
végétales c'est à dire des armes
voici l'europe il ya 20 minutes il ya
vingt mille ans dans le cadre des
fluctuations naturelles du climat car le
climat fluctue naturellement pas du tout
on est déjà dedans parce que nous sommes
en train de faire en ce moment mais il
faut que tu es aussi l'europe est plongé
comme la terre dure est dans une ère de
place et il fait froid
la géographie européenne ne ressemble
absolument pas à ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui alors d'abord n'exportait
pas en scandinavie passant sous la glace
vous avez un glacier de trois kilomètres
d'épaisseur qui recouvre la totalité de
la partie
bonne nouvelle pour les rugbymans les
irlandais les écossais sont aussi sous
la glace les canadiens sont aussi sous
la glace et une partie des sibériens
pour constituer ce et au delà sont il a
fallu prendre de l'eau et de barres et
la nature a opéré un énorme transfert
d'eau depuis l'océan la quantité
suffisante vers ses glaces continentales
et ce faisant le niveau de l'océan a
baissé de plus de 120 m donc il n'y a
pas un seul club de voile dans la manche
en france il n'y a pas de nouvelle
égérie
l'époque on voyait que le trait de côte
et quand même assez différent le climat
étant beaucoup plus froid il est
beaucoup plus sec dans un climat
beaucoup plus froid et moi d'évaporation
moins de précipitation et dans ce climat
froid et sec que nous avons à l'époque
la végétation française ressemble à ce
que vous avez aujourd'hui ou nord de la
sibérie c'est à dire de la star et dans
ce paysage là il n'avait pas beaucoup de
clients puisque il y à peu près cent
mille personnes qui résident en france
là on s'enrichit chasseurs cueilleurs
occupés à courir derrière des malouines
et à y accueillir des airelles nous
avons à l'évidence
quand l'europe est passée de l'état de
gauche avait pas de droite ça c'est bien
évidemment fait dans le cadre d'un
réchauffement planétaire
et bien ce réchauffement planétaire il
se limite à 4 à 5 degrés en dix mille
ans donc le réchauffement planétaire
global qui a opéré la déglaciation vous
voyez les faits sur ce sur scène deux
planches c'est juste 4 à 5 degrés de
région tant réchauffement pardon en cinq
à dix mille ans
de là je vais vous proposer une
conclusion premières conclusions avant
de rentrer dans le détail quatre degrés
de réchauffement en un siècle si on joue
à ce jeu là et même de aufait 4 ça sera
la guerre
ça sera l'effondrement le chaos la fin
des démocraties la fin de la paix vous
assurer que votre plante trésorerie
parce qu'elle fait là un petit morceau
de chez vous ça sera pas vraiment votre
votre souci
on voudrait bien que c'est avec ça qu'on
est en fin de vie c'est avec ça qu'on
est en train de jouer même degré c'est
déjà un effondrement partiel très
importants du monde même deux degrés
alors parlons de degré justement vous
avez ici le réchauffement planétaire
depuis 1950 sur une échelle où le zéro
correspond à la moyenne de la
température planétaire sur la période
1850 19 ans une double moyenne
géographique et temporel sur la période
1850 19 cents sur l'ensemble de la
planète et on regarde comment varie la
température planétaire par rapport à
ceux 0 à la fin du xxème début du xxième
siècle la température s'était déjà
réchauffé de 2 degrés alors 1,2 degré
qu'est-ce qu'on attend à 42 degrés à
biarritz il ya deux jours on a 50 degrés
au canada l'année dernière on a 50
degrés au pakistan il ya quelques mois
on a un tiers de la superficie française
qui a brûlé en australie un an et demi
on a 15 % des gros qui sont déjà morts
on a des ouragans qui passe de catégorie
1 à 5 en 24 heures voilà on a déjà ce
genre de plaisanterie 800 personnes qui
sont des inondations
en belgique et en allemagne il ya pas
très longtemps et ça c'est juste un
degré à un degré on sait également que
10 % de la forêt française va déjà
courir parce que vous avez déjà un
certain nombre d'espèces qui sont en
dehors de la zone de survie alors ils
vont mettre du temps à un arbre ça met
du temps à se dessécher mais ils vont
finir par mourir rien qu'à ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui
et là vous voyez comment pourrait
évoluer la température à l'avenir alors
une température par an un scénario dans
lequel on appuie très très fort vous
allez voir ce que ça signifie sur la
[ __ ] de frein de maintenant limiterait
le réchauffement à 1,5 à 2 degrés un
scénario dans lequel on laisse le
charbon se vivre toute sa vie autant
qu'il peut parce que c'est
essentiellement en charbon il ya le
reste des réserves président
problème
mais jargon il en reste donc charon est
ce que ça donne on parle dans le
scénario le plus haut de 4 4,5 degrés
dans ce scénario le plus bas dans le
même sac à dos en fait le scénario plus
haut moi j'y crois pas parce que la
trajectoire que ça suppose sur un monde
dont l'économie se porte bien organisés
et ses limites bien avant la fin du 21e
siècle
cela supposera une économie en très
forte croissance jusqu'à la fin du 21e
siècle les premiers emmerdements du
changement climatique et la pénurie de
ressources qui vont qui va s'accroître
notamment sur la deuxième moitié du
xxième siècle interdisent à mon avis
totalement en suisse ce genre de
scénario ça veut dire que la régulation
a volontaires arrivent à bout le
scénario bas vous allez voir que c'est
une vraie question est ce qu'on va
arriver à suivre ce scénario là pardon
parce que ça suppose un effort gérer
alors à tête le suivre
donc pour moi on va se balader quelque
part entre ça et ça et le scénario jaune
mais dans un monde où c'est
essentiellement la limitation sur les
ressources qui va se charger de remettre
et à ce moment on n'aura plus
d'engagement avec moins de moyens
on aura les canicules
mais en beaucoup plus ce que vous voyez
ici c'est que sur les 20 années qui
viennent en fait sur les vingt ans qui
suivent le début d'un scénario vous
voyez pas beaucoup de différences entre
les scénarios c'est dû à la très forte
inertie du co2 dans l'atmosphère et
partant la très forte inertie du système
climatique ou les modifications des
missions ne se voit pas beau dans les
vingt premières années
je vais vous le dire autrement de toute
façon quoi qu'on fasse à l'avenir même
en cas de réduction planétaire organisé
forte des éditions les emmerdements vont
continuer à augmenter de manière
significative
voilà c'est exactement ça qu'il faut
retenir que je vais vous le dire encore
autres dans le jeu on décide que la
plaisanterie a assez duré et qu'on va se
mettre à lutter de façon ference contre
le réchauffement climatique la seule
garantie qu'on a à ce moment là c'est
que les environnements
je vous dis là je le dis depuis 20 ans
c'est pas illégaux et en cédant les
rapports scientifiques depuis 20 ans
donc si vous êtes surpris
c'est pas de ma faute
c'est de la vieille science
par une canicule puisque ses actualités
récentes
la fréquence d'occurrence des canicules
va augmenter beaucoup plus vite que
l'élévation de température prenez un
événement qui arrive une fois tous les
deux siècles
dans un monde qui se réchauffe de 1,5
degré ce que vous voyez là il arrive
quasiment dix fois plus souvent ou plus
exactement le seuil qui était dépassé
une fois par demi siècle est dépassé
quasiment dix fois par demi siècle et
quand ce seuil est dépassé il est
dépassé de quasiment 2 degrés
dans un monde à 4 degrés ce seuil est
dépassé une fois par demi siècle et
dépassées quasiment tous les angles
avec une température maximale atteinte
qu'ils aient augmenté de 5 degrés par
rapport à l'épisode le plus chaud du
demi siècle dans le climat passé
donc ce que nous avons vécu il ya deux
jours dans un climat qui se réchauffe ça
paraîtra une plaisanterie
dans la deuxième moitié du vingtième du
21e siècle
si on continue sur notre trajectoire
l'été 2003 sera un été frais dans la
deuxième moitié du xxième siècle alors
vous allez me dire la deuxième moitié du
xxème siècle c'est un peu loin pour mon
plan de trésorerie certes mais ça veut
quand même dire que l'activité qui
consistera à manger va être un peu
compliqué dans ce monde blanc si vous
avez des enfants et petits-enfants voilà
un peu les concerts dans un monde qui se
serait réchauffé de 4 degrés vous avez
ici là quand le nombre de jours par an
où les conditions extérieures sont
potentiellement létale dont les êtres
humains parce que la température dépasse
la température de la peau et l'air est
saturé d'humidité
c'est à dire que vous ne pouvez pas
refroidir votre corps en transpirant ya
plus de place pour accueillir la sueur
qui s'est d'abord réduit votre post
scolaire est déjà saturé d'humidité
france n'a pris que c'est
essentiellement la région équatoriale ya
à peu près allez on va dire un milliard
de milliards de personnes concernées
dont vous avez deux milliards de
personnes et même dans un monde à deux
degrés vous avez plus d'un milliard de
gens qui sont concernés c'est-à-dire
qu'ils risquent leur peau en sortant
dehors
c'est comme s'ils vivaient dans un
hammam permanent le hammam vous y rendre
vous y restez pas cinq heures
si vous devez vivre dans un hammam toute
la journée on comprenait que c'est
compliqué pas rester vivant très
longtemps c'est exactement ce qui risque
de se passer de se produire d'une
certaine manière
l'augmentation des précipitations va se
faire de manière disparate il ya un
certain nombre de régions dans le monde
où cette augmentation n'aura pas lieu ce
sera une baisse et en plus d'évaporation
va augmenter à cause de l'élévation de
température ce qui veut dire que dans
énormément de régions du monde les sols
asséchés vous voyez ici on aura toutes
les régions du monde où les seins de sa
sage
l'objectif politique oui tout le
pourtour du bassin méditerranéen toute
la chine quasiment tout le continent
américain toute l'afrique du sud
problème et nous et nous et donc
quand vous voyez en particulier pas mal
de grandes régions céréalières dans le
monde qui sont directement impactés par
ce phénomène de ce fait les rendements
vont baisser et le giec il ya deux ans
et demi a publié un graphique dans
lequel il disait que à partir de deux
degrés de degré et demi c'est ça la
signification du violet sur sa graphique
l'insécurité alimentaire devient
généralisation d'ailleurs c'est à dire
que la sécurité alimentaire devient
quelque chose de récurrent dans le
paysage les forêts vont brûler de plus
en plus facilement il tente une forêt
brûle il faut n'importe quoi en
plus d'avoir entre derrière
il ya un papier scientifique qui est
sorti il ya pas longtemps disant que en
amazonie on n'était probablement pas
très loin du point de bascule où la
forêt tropicale pourrait se transformer
en forêt s'agit ferran savall à cause de
la modification des conditions
climatiques je vous rappelle que
l'amazone y fait partie des endroits qui
devrait s'assécher manière évidemment la
déforestation augmentent le problème
les ouragans vont s'intensifier ça je
pourrais répondre à des questions aussi
le niveau de l'océan va monter parce que
au chaud donc plus de place que l'eau
froide un lot se dit d'accord pour la
chauffe est parce qu on fait fondre les
glaces ont posé sur la terre notamment
des gros glaçon le groenland a commencé
à fondre et maintenant c'est
irréversible et l'antarctique de l'ouest
est à risque de déstabilisation
l'antarctique de l'ouest est un vaste
château de cartes de glacières que
goûter les uns contre les autres tout ça
est posée sur un socle soumah sénat truc
très instable et que ça pourrait
déstabiliser en partie ou en totalité ce
qui fait que comme pour les contrats
d'assurance si vous lisez les petites
lignes du dernier rapport du giec ils
vous disent qu alors ils ont deux mille
trois cents
on ne peut pas exclure une élévation du
niveau de la mer de plus de 15 mètres
alors plus de 15 mais ça veut dire qu'il
ya plus une ville d'environ
plus
au moins 1 2306 en suisse scénario et
d'une mondialisation à mon avis ce sera
bon mais voilà vous voyez ce genre de
conséquences j'aurais dû continuer alors
si on veut pas jouer trop avec le feu
quel est le cahier des charges cette
affaire je vais m'arrêter là vous avez
ici une cour deuxième droite très
importante qui vous donne la réponse en
température du système climatique
planétaire en fonction de la quantité
totale de co2 qu'on met dans
l'atmosphère alors applications
numériques comment 10e temps en 2020 à
fin 2020 on avait mis 2300 milliards de
tonnes de co2 dans l'atmosphère et du
coup la température s'est réchauffée de
1,2
si on veut se limiter à 25 degrés c'est
très simple il faut pas aller au delà de
3000 milliards de tonnes émises dans
l'atmosphère dont 2300 déjà été émise
donc quand vous êtes des gens qui
s'achètent des comptes comme moi 3000
moins de 1300 sept ans
ça veut dire que le budget carbone qui
nous restent à émettre d'ici à 2100 si
on reste limitée à 5 de ses 700
milliards de tonnes c'est à dire un
petit tiers de ce que nous avons aimé
dans le passé est essentiellement depuis
la première
avec une population planétaire qui
étaient en moyenne deux à trois fois
moins nombreuse ça dépend de leur
exemple quand vous prenez ce qui veut
dire qu'un être humain qui démarre sa
vie aujourd'hui
il a le droit à sa vie durant six heures
à 80 ans des maîtres de langue seconde
la du dixième de ce que ses
grands-parents qui serait mort
aujourd'hui en libye pendant l'envi
de l'ordre du dixième scénario
compte tenu de ce que les énergies
fossiles représentent dans l'énergie et
de ce que l'énergie représente en termes
de parc de machines ça revient à dire
qu'au premier ordre sans pouvoir d'achat
cumulée sur sa vie lors du 10e 2 0
o
en
c'est ça vient quand même 5 degrés alors
ok je vous le fais au 8e en faire un peu
d'efficacité
vous comprenez ce que ça veut dire
c'est pareil juste un truc technique
jamais juste avec la technique les
ordres de grandeur sont pas du tout là
j'ai pas le temps de détailler ce soir
mais il ya sur mon site perso un truc
qui s'appelle qu'est-ce que l'équation
de caillasser une petite règle de trois
qui dissertent sur le problème je vous
invite à aller lire dans la bd ou si
vous vous rendez compte que on n'y
arrivera pas juste avec démarche
technique c'est juste impossible la
physique le permet pas donc si on est
sérieux sur le climat ça veut dire qu'on
ce nouveau régime en ce qui concerne
voilà donc chaque année on a un peu
moins de boîtes de conserve que l'année
d'avant
adro croissance dans cette histoire
donc
alors il ya évidemment des gens qui vont
qui peuvent en profiter est ce que je
veux dire c'est que globalement on parle
bien d'une mise au régime c'est de ça
dont on parle globalement
même à 2 degrés 2° il faut se limiter à
prendre 1500 milliards de tonnes dont
2300 etc allez on bd il a le droit
d'émettre sa vie durant le dîner
aujourd'hui le cinquième de ce que ses
grands parents qui n'ont aujourd'hui
une autre manière de présenter la même
chose c'est de dire qu' il faut que les
émissions soit divisé par trois au moins
d'ici à 2050 et s'il ya un banquier dans
la salle
une division par trois en trente ans 28
c'est de l'ordre d'une baisse de 5% par
an ça veut dire qu'il faut que les
émissions baisse de 5% par an tous les
angles 5% de baisse on a vu ce que
c'était récemment c'est 2020 en 2020 les
émissions planétaires ont baissé de 5%
eh bien il faudra répéter cette baisse
tous les angles supplémentaires par
rapport à la situation de l'année
d'avant pour avoir une chance d'obtenir
les 2 degrés tous les angles c'est ça
que ça veut dire
donc il est évident aujourd'hui on en
parle on n'a absolument pas le quart de
la moitié du début d'une initiative
sérieuse pour arriver à cet objectif
en
cause sa session
absolument pas dans les clous pour aller
à la bonne vitesse et je parle bien go
au niveau planétaire
je vais finir avec ce petit camembert
qui vous donne la décomposition des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le monde c'est celle là même qu'il faut
baisser de 5% à 20% des émissions c'est
les centrales à charbon dont la moitié
sont en chine donc dès que vous utilisez
quelque chose qui est made in china ou
utiliser un truc et du charbon
une machine outil qu'est cheyrou un
composant de machines-outils kg ou
du nickel qui a été raffiné en chine n'a
pas toi d'accord des verres de lunettes
jean 7 à 10% c'est les émissions des
centrales à garde donc la production
électrique à base de charbon et de gaz
en 2020 c'était un gros quart des
émissions planétaires
4% des émissions planétaires c'est les
cimenteries donc la construction des
villes ça fait notamment appel à 112%
c'est les émissions directes je vois pas
d'électricité consommée les autres
procédés industriels là dedans vous avez
un nouveau cap pour cent pour la chimie
et 4% pour
la métallurgie
dont 15% lasimant la cimenterie 4% la
syrie 4% et chimie l'industrie
agroalimentaire qui concerne
le chauffage des bâtiments ces cinq pour
cent des émissions planétaires
14 % c'est les transports dans
lesquelles vous avez 6 pour les voitures
4 pour les camions 2 pour la marine
marchande et deux pour les avions les
camions et la marine marchande accès les
objets de la mondialisation dans un
monde dans lequel demain matin je
supprime les porteurs des minéraliers et
les camions il ya plus de mondialisation
ce qui veut dire que la mondialisation
c'est du pétrole parce qu'on ne
lectrices ira pas cent mille bateaux de
la marine marchande de plus de 100
tonnes de port en lourd on électrifie
rappaz le camion sur terre
on électrifie rappaz 2 milliards de
voitures sur terre
elle est très fier les voitures voiture
la mondialisation
marchande 1% des émissions c'est le
l'agriculture là dedans vous avez comme
je disais tout à l'heure les ruminants 1
25 milliard de vaches sur terre vous
avez les rizières vous avez les
émissions de protoxyde d azote une fois
qu'on a épandu les engrais azotés dans
les champs
quand vous écoutez les anglais aiment ça
vous fait des émissions protoxyde
d'azoté et vous avez une part marginale
là-dedans keane co2 détracteurs 10%
c'est la déforestation la déforestation
est un processus amont de l'activité
agricole essentiellement ou des surfaces
pour faire des champs les ce qui veut
dire que l'agriculture au sens large
déforestation à cusset un tiers des
émissions planétaires donc c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement conséquent
dans l'ensemble et là vous avez deux
drivers aux évictions d'origine agricole
des arrestations à cusset la taille de
la population et la part d'aliments
carnés dans la diète en eau la gym
alimentaire c'est ça les deux
déterminants delà de ces émissions et
enfin les quelques % qui restent là
c'est gestion des déchets gestion des
groupes froids les
deux tiers de pinte a fait 5 60% c'est
l'énergie si je fais un focus sur les
émissions d'origine agricole les sols
voici donc la déforestation arrive en
tête le cheptel bovin arrive derrière
des rizières l'épandage des engrais et
vous voyez les tracteurs sait pas grand
chose vous allez me dire bon c'est trop
horrible c'est pas grave on va apprendre
de degré de confiance gérer les
conséquences
alors moi je vais vous dire oui très
bien il ya de toute façon un deuxième
truc qui va faire baisser les émissions
même si ça ne vous plaît pas c'est que
les combustibles fossiles sont en
quantité finie ici vous avez un document
qui est totalement passé sous le radar
de la presse française
public 1 qui est le world energy outlook
d'une agence internationale de l'énergie
de 2018 et il est écrit noir sur blanc
ce que moi je voulais me rouge sur blanc
c'est à dire la production de l'ensemble
du pétrole dans le monde hors pétrole de
schiste et sables bitumineux est passé
par un maximum en 2008 et a commencé à
décliner depuis
on a tiré par la manche un cadre deux
anciens cadres dirigeants de total
l'ancien patron de l'exploration et
l'ancien patron de l'évaluation des
vivants l'ancien analyste pétrole et gaz
de l'eeie on leur a acheté pour une
bouchée de pain sinon j'avais eu les
moyens une base de données concernant
l'ensemble des gisements pétroliers dans
le monde et on leur a demandé de nous
faire un pronostic sur ce que serait la
production des 16 premiers fournisseurs
de l'europe à l'avenir sous sol
contraintes géologiques donc là il ya
une émanation climat
il se trouve que ses 16 premiers
fournisseurs de l'europe sont aussi les
16 premiers producteurs mondiaux
exception faite du brésil et du canada
le résultat vous l'avez soulevées même
si les gilet jaune ne sont pas contents
et bien à l'horizon 2050 la production
de ces espèces due à la production
devrait être divisé par plus de deux ce
qui veut dire que les exportations de
ces pays vers l'europe qui importe 95 %
de son pétrole seront divisés par deux à
nice
gilet jaune pas gilet jaune pas clean
voilà
ça a déjà commencé en fait ce mouvement
ici vous avez l'approvisionnement
énergétique de l'union européenne et
vous voyez que au moment où le monde
passe son pic de production du pétrole
il commence à décliner alors qu'avant
ils n'arrêtaient pas de remonter et ceci
allant avec cela vous avez ici par
exemple la variation du taux de
croissance de la zone ocde ses rangs
et vous voulez qu'ils n'arrêtent pas de
baisser et normalement ça va continuer
donc pour conclure cet exposé
l'avenir qui nous attend j'ai envie de
dire de manière structurelle je parle
pas juste de l'année prochaine manche à
tous et bon mais à l'horizon de quelques
décennies ce qui nous attend c'est
structurellement de moins en moins
d'énergie pour faire face à de plus en
plus d'angle
parce que climat planétaire dépend des
émissions planétaires n'est pas juste
des efforts que nous devons de toute
façon qu'ils arrêtent pas de sujet
climat on doit de toute façon il fallait
que nous devons faire en france pour
décarbonés notre économie encore une
fois même s'il y avait pas de sujet
climat on doit les faire parce que
l'approvisionnement la maison
voilà c'est très exactement ça qui nous
attend est aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
vraiment les outils le bagage technique
le maïs est comme diraient les anglais
la boîte à outils pour nous attaquer à
ce problème alors c'est ce qu'on essaye
connaissent de faire un quart 24 mai
mais c'est très exactement à ce sens qui
va être de plus en plus souvent
va s'inviter de plus en plus souvent
dans notre paysage et s'invitera sont
des formes qui seront à chaque fois des
surprises
donc le colis de la gare en ukraine
scéne et illustrations possible ce qui
est sûr encore une fois c'est que c'est
mathématiquement certain que une
ressource données en quantité définie
une fois pour toutes
son extraction de me faire de ça au fil
du temps donc je ne sais pas vous dire
exactement quand et sous quelle forme
est ce que ça sera une guerre sera un
défaut de l'italie sont ses adeptes
comme gens s'ils foutent rien par contre
ce que je sais c'est qu'aujourd'hui
l'équilibré très fortement instable et
donc il y aura des mécanismes correctifs
très désagréable qui vont s'appliquer de
manière croissante au fil du temps sinon
j'aime pas la situation
où vous avez évoqué une prise des
licences approfondie chose c'est une
augmentation des coûts dacia
est ce qu'il ya un impact
tant que quel est il tant qu'on n'est
pas limité sur les ressources
tant qu'il n'y a pas de facteur limitant
sur la possibilité de recourir aux
ressources
la quantité consomment sur terre elle
est proportionnelle à la population donc
oui il ya un impact évident de la
démocratie mais il a eu un impact de
l'énergie sur la démographie
la très forte hausse de la production
agricole mondiale
vient notamment de l'abondance
énergétique et donc ça veut dire que
sens dans un monde sans énergie
abondante pas complètement sûr on serait
montés à lui milliards
donc ça marche dans les deux sens à la
verse
oui oui absolument c'est à peu près sûr
c'est la pression que ça va se passer
alors les décrues il y en a des
sympathiques on laisse les vieux mourir
et on fait moins un enfant il y en a des
moins sympathique qui s'appelle les
pandémies et les famines ou nantes 1,8 c
est une année les morts de la
circulation d'ailleurs
beaucoup moins que le tabac
donc non commises pour me lancer un truc
sérieuse et la peste
d'appel en disant vous avez la moitié de
la population qu'il y passe
on n'est pas du tout à l'abri du retour
de quelque chose de très méchant non
seulement on n'est pas à l'abri mais
je dis pas que je suis ravi qu'il en
soit ainsi juste ça fait partie des
mécanismes de régulation qui existent
et qui sont dans notre monde
interconnecté en plus ça ira assez vite
parce que comme on se rendra compte
après coup que le virus a circulé
regardez decaux vide je veux dire cette
année d'un point au point de la terre la
paix cet article mais aussi populaire
donc là ça fait très très vite
j'ai eu l'occasion de vous entendre une
conférence à sciences po là vous poser
de problème sur la provence déjà de
décider des solutions je pense qu'il
faudrait deux à tous ensemble parce que
là vous aider à générer un peu
d'inquiétude avait quelque part chez les
femmes moi je trouvais que vous dessinez
à reichenau que l'on n'est pas prêt
il ya un éternel débat quand on
s'intéresse à ce problème qui est de
savoir si on doit commencer par la
solution si on doit commencer par le
problème si on doit commencer par les
deux à la fois les deux à la fois ça
suppose souvent un créneau horaire
aujourd'hui trois heures
après il faut choisir si je parle juste
de la solution la solution peut paraître
un mur trop à franchir pour des gens qui
n'ont pas conscience de l'importance du
problème donc il y aura non pas y aller
en réalisant ou pas de toute façon que
troisième et si on commence à esquisser
et là j'ai juste esquissé parce que
chacune de mes diapos j'aurais pu avoir
derrière un développement avec une heure
supplémentaire vous expliquer comment
fonctionne le système climatique comment
on sait où est ce qu'il ya une assurance
raisonnable et où est ce qu'il ya des
choses qui sont là où est-ce que
l'incertitude risque de jouer en
défaveur
en particulier sur la variabilité du
climat l'incertitude va probablement
joué en notre défaveur il ya quelques
années
2050 il se trouve que les températures
cas mentionné sur son faux bulletins
météo en 2050 c'est celle qu'on a eu il
ya quelques jours donc
donc là l'incertitude est le fait que
les scientifiques et des prudent en
disant bas si on n'est pas sûr on va pas
en parler ça a joué en notre défaveur
parce que il aurait dû être beaucoup
plus alarmiste en disant vous savez ça
va nous tomber dessus beaucoup plus vite
que l'idée qu'on s'en fait donc le la
question de l'allocation du temps quand
le temps est compté et toujours un sujet
compliqué
o'shea project on a travaillé sur les
deux dernières années à quelque chose
qu'on a appelé le plan de transformation
de l'économie française qu'on avait calé
sur l'élection présidentielle alors
maintenant qu'on a un président sans
majorité je pense qu'on peut le ranger
dans vos cartons pour un certain temps
ça fait des conséquences
parce que je vois mal comment on peut
conduire ce qui s'apparente quand même
quelque part à l'effort de guerre
avec un gouvernement qui est en minorité
enfin majorité relative au parlement
je portais pas spécialement monsieur mac
ont donc en l'occurrence là on est dans
une configuration
qui va être une configuration
particulièrement bloquante pour faire
n'importe quoi dans le district ifs dans
un sens ou dans l'autre
il n'empêche que ce plan de
transformation de l'économie française
il peut quand même donné lieu et inspiré
tota pas des initiatives de terrain donc
les gens peuvent le lire et se dire
tiens je comprends dans quelle direction
générale il faut aller et à mon échelle
même sans changement du cadre organisé
seront difficiles je peux essayer de
faire des choses qui vont dans la bonne
direction il ya quand même un certain
nombre de sujets sur lesquels on a
besoin d'un cadre organisé et si je
prends un exemple qui vous concernent de
près on propose dans le plan de
transformation de l'économie française
de mettre plus de monde dans
l'agriculture tout en divisant par un
facteur 2 à 3 les productions animales
donc là normalement tout bon sens et au
plafond
il est hors de question de faire ça dans
un cadre qui ne soit pas un cadre un peu
organisés
alors il ya des initiatives qui
commencent à apparaître ici et là
des machins mais quand vous regardez
l'évolution globale elle continue à
partir dans la mauvaise direction
continue à avoir une concentration des
trucs de plus en plus capitalistiques
dès qu'on continue à arracher la
monoculture qui se spécialisent de plus
en plus par bassin
pas du tout
globalement on
dit toujours qu'il ya plein de mails
dans le sud-ouest ont
globalement la déspécialisation très
rapide qu'il faudrait avoir des bassins
agricoles ou là on n'a pas du tout
rentable et donc il faudrait aller
beaucoup plus vite en fait il faudrait
prendre des directions il est très
rapidement de direction est hors cadre
global c'est juste impensable qu'en plus
une partie du câble
ce qui rajoute un d'éléments de rigidité
supplémentaire dans le processus
voilà donc c'est clair que la situation
dans laquelle on se retrouve là
aujourd'hui et pas simple et elle est
notamment dû malheureusement au fait que
pendant de trop nombreuses années au
lieu de s'attaquer aux problèmes tels
qu'ils se présentent qui est celui que
je vous évoquez parce que ce n'est
pas tellement je trouve et on a continué
à se bercer de l'illusion qu'on allait
pouvoir faire perdurer encore très
longtemps le système dans lequel nous
savons
et qu'on pouvait affecter les moyens qui
nous que nous avons aujourd'hui à
essayer de continuer à optimiser encore
plus finement un système qui va bientôt
sortir de sa zone de confort
donc on a fait une très mauvaise
allocation de danse hausse
malheureusement ce qui est fait est fait
et donc parler des solutions c'est un
chantier en soit je vous invite à lire
ce bouquin dans la transformation de
l'économie française et tous les
rapports sectoriels qui vont derrière
disponibles
c'est essentiellement à ça qu'on essaye
de travailler
pour finir avec un
petite remarque
un peu cache pas pas du tout énervé il y
avait un peu gâché quand ces dernières
années ont
battu la campagne pour dire aux
entreprises parce que je suis project
est financé par les entreprises souple
et doux pour qu'on puisse travailler à
la manière de décarbonés l'économie
ça a jamais été extrêmement prioritaire
pour l'essentiel des entreprises
le budget de l'association
pour vous dire c'est pas trés trés luo
façon 80 milliards
pour les quatre clubs allemands
aujourd'hui les acteurs économiques
continuent à ne pas investir de moyens
dans la préparation
du monde peut le garder vos gains d'où
le fait que quand on découvre le constat
on se dit ça rajoute on est un peu moins
de 6 pouces mon stock est effectivement
est dure à prendre
seront on la fait tous un petit peu
pionnier en fait on repasse
la question c'est est ce que vous pensez
pas que
qu'est ce que vous pensez des nouvelles
générations
confondues
vous insistez beaucoup sur le fait de
former les dirigeants politiques par la
citibank que l'associé que les
politiques n'ont pas compris
la société civile ça dépend
4 quand même une zone d'espoir
enfants à comprendre pour pouvoir son
sujet n'a la réponse est non il n'y a
pas d'espoir de pouvoir
le pouvoir c'est nous dans cette salle
qui l'avons fait mais on n'a pas le
temps d'attendre le pouvoir sait nous
dans cette salle aujourd'hui qui
l'attend en temps c'est une des sources
de clients payent qu'on a quatre
mais c'est le seul pouvoir qu'ils ont
c'est le pouvoir qui l'ont fait passer
une danse elle en parlant
il ya des envois arriver par exemple
qu'ils disent mes enfants walbach votre
enfant ça ça les secours
on envoie voilà quand elle ce genre de
choses là où il se réveille un peu mais
sinon c'est à new generation
mais je le redis c'est à nous
c'est donc avant les malades
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]